do you remember what the rule was we've
got a fixed point and a fixed the line
and then you've got some point that sort
of hovers around and it's the same
distance from each okay so let's put
some let's put some words on this and on
some coordinates rather I seem to be
liking the coordinates 1 comma negative
3 so let's use those 1 comma negative 3
okay now in order to keep this a little
bit simple negative 3 where's that okay
sure let's make this equation here a
horizontal line I'm going to place it I
don't want to place it at negative 5
okay now we're going to have a look at
more interesting versions of this
equation in the future but keeping it
simple first if I want to work out the
distance from this point to this guy
over here I'm going to call this s for
reasons that are inscrutable right now
will remain inscrutable even when you
find out what what it means I'm gonna
call this line here L for line I use the
cursive L because as non cursive ljus
looks like a 1 so therefore my equation
that's going to tell me what this is
doing is going to be P s that's the
distance to the fixed point equals P L
that's the distance to the fixed line is
that okay okay what's it's going to look
like in algebraic terms well two points
I've used this like three times already
right this is going to be the square
root of in fact it's exactly the same
square root because I've given you the
same points as I'm we've used in the
last two examples so it's going to be X
minus 1 squared y plus 3 squared I
remember it quickly yeah equals okay now
if you use the distance formula between
two points a few times but now we need
the distance we'll move between not two
points but a point and sorry yeah a
point and a line a point in a line I'm
gonna have to dig back into here right
what's that formula called for the
perpendicular distance right now maybe
it will help you it was just you
- right off on the side here the
perpendicular distance four-wheel it's a
fraction does anyone remember what's on
the top absolute value and then what a
x1 plus B y1 plus C and then on the
bottom you've got the square root which
we get from Pythagoras okay so that's
the perpendicular distance formula but
what does it look like for this okay
think carefully
for starters a B and C what are they a b
and c a b and c are the coefficients of
this straight line in what form because
they're not just any coefficients in any
form in general form right is this in
general form no so I need to rewrite it
in general form how many X terms are
there 0 so I'm gonna write 0x how many Y
terms are there 1 1 Y what's the
constant plus 5 because I need for
general form the right-hand side to be 0
is that okay so now I write it in that
awkward form with 0x of 1 why because
that helps me substitute into the
perpendicular distance formula properly
in fact if you have a look what are the
x and y coordinates at the point that
I'm interested in what are the x and y
coordinates they're just X&Y okay
because this point moves does that make
sense
so therefore this line up here is going
to be exactly what I wrote over here
that's convenient isn't it 0 X plus 1 y
plus 5 all divided by what's in here a
squared plus B squared okay
all right I can work with this right
let's simplify this a little bit I've
got I'll leave the left hand side as it
is for a brief moment there's the left
hand side what ends up happening on the
right hand side what's on the what is
left in the absolute value I have to
actually simplify stuff out like y plus
5 and on the denominator square root of
1 which is just 1 so
I'm just gonna do that are you happy
with that okay now in the past we've
squared out things because we don't like
this square root so let's just do it
again X minus one squared y plus three
squared equals what this is really nice
because I had this we talked absolute
value here which I don't even know what
to do with it but if you square it
doesn't matter because what you're going
to get is positive anyway so no big deal
okay now I'm gonna leave this X minus y
squared here sorry X minus one squared
here for a minute
because if you have a look at the
right-hand side what happens hmm X minus
one squared plus y squared plus 6y plus
9 right hand side mmm what cancels Y
Squared's are gone that's a relief okay
you can see I've then got Y terms and
then I've got constant terms I'm gonna
leave this guy over here that's fine
what do I get on the right-hand side how
many Y's will there be left there will
be four of them and then how many
constants 25 minus 9 is 16 yeah all
right are you happy with that okay I
could probably make this nicer in one
more way if I make Y this subject
because I'm used to seeing Y is the
subject with all of my equations in
coordinate geometry so I guess I will
subtract 16 from both sides and then
divide by 4 is that okay so that gives
me this
you happy with that is that Marriot with
what you expect it
what's really nice is you can go ahead
you can pop this guy into des moss you
can pop this kind of des mots we're out
of time right now and then pop this guy
in and then just see it unfold before
your eyes okay